you're not any hot he's gonna look at
guys I did like okay face hi I'm Cathy
I'm Jarrod
and we've been dating for almost a year
you know last time we were in a BuzzFeed
video together we weren't even like a
fish we're just hanging out we're just
boning so this is actually our first
holiday season together so this is gonna
be our first time giving each other big
holiday gifts but I'm broke so this is
this whole hundred dollar and under
thing is perfect jared is the most
giving person I've ever met in my life
like if I just flippantly say like oh
man I'm out of like sponges for the
kitchen he'd get some shipped to my
house all the time it's not fair that's
great I feel like it's gonna be really
hard for me to find something for you
because you have everything you have me
that's that's really what matters yeah
but what are the three categories that
we're having to do I believe it's
sentimental useful incomes here okay the
thing about us is that we like to buy
experiences and not saying it was so
like making memories so I think there's
gonna be a bit of a challenge to get
something like sent in the mail yeah so
I'm gonna go first
okay don't walk okay so I'm gonna tell
you something that I'm not getting you
but almost got you okay and so there was
a mug cause he loved coffee oh yes I was
like I love you for your personality but
that dick is really nice thanks for all
the orgasms which like there's a time to
thank someone for that the holidays but
let's just start with the meaningful
because that one's really easy for me
okay so I'm gonna get this for the
sentiment
it has five-star view this gift
encapsulates like a very special memory
oh nice okay here's the other thing
though it might just I might have to buy
the second part don't we didn't like the
size that's the smallest a size 20 so
we're looking at it now looking at a
painting now sentiments a little picture
painting put it together I'm trying to
think how big is 12 by 16
that's eight bytes whoa so it's gonna be
like so $25 I like me in for this
meaningful gift dime but I am sweating
I'm stressed okay I'm getting this
useful gift because I think if you have
this maybe sometimes you would leave me
alone okay for the couple's gift I
definitely think this is something of
both enjoy so what am I at now if I'm at
25 plus 30 38 so what I've got weed me
out of 117 and the tube no 1662 coupon
which is a great thing if you want to do
experiences and make memories over
something tangible okay oh oh I'm liking
it Oh
oh you don't say oh I found it I found
it
oh wow oh it has to be a couple's gift
right didn't - gift for herself it's
something for one person so 87 that's a
little much yeah yeah that should be
fine I'm gonna go ahead and say it's
fine okay this is perfect okay I'm
actually pretty calm to find out what
this is now well I guess I'm up I got a
couple ideas
so with Kelsey we're looking at Harry
Potter we're looking at the color green
yeah okay we're gonna add rose gold you
know you know yeah we're looking at
Harry Potter
yeah I'm gonna get you a meaningful one
first okay that's here that we both
thought of meaningful things first how
cheesy early my my meeting for one is
like a little it's also semi useful okay
if he was smart he would have just gone
to my Amazon wishlist
oh you think of that mm-hmm oh they
changed no what
that's unfortunate they change the price
in on me that yes double the price
that's why I guess we're going back to
Amazon yeah love if one day you just
surprised me and jetted me off to like
Tokyo or something wouldn't that be nice
that's what every girl wants right every
girl just wants a one time a private jet
somewhere you don't have one day but I'm
gonna do it myself I don't need a man to
get it for me I don't need you to get it
for me I'm gonna get it myself okay yes
I am I'm doing a definite audible year
so it's a football term it is yeah
when you've called an audible you could
hear it to the other players I know what
it is okay I got one this is a real this
you like this oh yeah yeah yeah now the
question is which ones do I get see the
downside is these are all four stars
like there's no five-star version of
this I'm a 5 star girl Jared do you
think I've ever gotten you a really good
gift what's your favorite gift that I
have gotten you what did you get me I've
got it awesome everyone we make we're
one life remember at that did we go it
was last month
I know Jared pretty cool oh wait a
minute
also be getting a couple's technically
this is a couple's it's really not okay
okay now you know what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna is it okay because the the
couple's gift is actually so what I was
going for it wasn't actually a couple's
gift I blanked this is the couple's gift
right now so you already got something
that's useful and you got something that
is meaningful sentimental okay okay I
got it
how much do you spend oh wow sixty-two
dollars that's it you can give me some
of your budget to get one more thing
that I needed okay I'll give you I'll
give you a budget okay okay okay go back
to my thing
what a treat just giving me give me a
little extra and I'll uh I'll buy you
more sponges to your house less paper
towels this is something that I need
it's the part of the same first gift I
just need this to like finish it we did
it how do you think he did I
I killed it I mean I didn't real well
this was way less stressful than going
out to like a store in the mall to try
and get you something so they're all
ordered we shall reconvene
once the presents arrive see that bye
so it's been a week the stuff has
arrived I think I hope we'll find out
and we're gonna exchange and be happy
right that's the point of this is all
stuff under a hundred dollars plus or
minus a few dollars from my extra thing
sorry like I'm mad about that guy so
I'll go first with like the useful thing
close your eyes well I set it up okay
your luck Oh fun what is it look cute
baby
uh-huh yeah
Jared has like a pretty severe addiction
to chess and other like brain games a
little cute oh yeah look that'll keep
that by my desk and oh you actually is
it please yeah do you think it's a
useful gift it's useful absolutely
okay thank you brain you're welcome
helps my brain it's like a stocking
stuffer you know how I like that that's
good I think I can also read it if I
need to I wouldn't think it all right
having it yep
sim is it is it a vibrator it's the
lights the light strings control your
phone and everything no he was smart he
would have just gone to my Amazon
wishlist I've been asking for these line
of white I'm gonna kill this so this is
like LED lights that you it's a strip of
color changing lights that you put up in
your apartment you can change them with
your phone
and I really want them because when I
shoot things I want to be able to change
the background in colors like make it
more dynamic so it is really you its mom
did we say heartfelt okay so yep okay
you're gonna open your eyes so here's
the thing is I got you a picture of
something but the thing didn't come they
just told me and hey guys that's the
dangers hey you describe it to you
online yeah it may or may not get there
ty so you take the poor risk and you
have to pay for yeah all I got it's so
beautiful thank you wow it's the
beautiful frame that you could actually
gave me the budget for okay inside oh
that's amazing oh that's cute
I love that so do you know what the
heart every guy's loved you yeah that's
so much better than mine adorable map
and I have a little like heart oh please
that he told me you love me for the
first time in Barcelona sentimental
right yes all right well it's not gonna
measure up nearly as good as that one
yeah
since we all know Kelsey's favorite
thing in the entire line cat no food
actually yeah true okay well never mind
here you go yep we were putting up a
tree and I saw there were no Harry
Potter Christmas ornaments up there so I
figured I'd get you a little little harm
Ronnie hurt ya sorry Cara ball Hermione
it's very cute and we just got a new
Christmas tree we did there's the cat
feet on the other one yep so we got a
new one and I was gonna have to throw
away all the ornaments could've all that
work so you're filling it out there you
go it's our first ornament together oh
my gosh door wall thank you
yeah well you're right mine was better
yeah way better now we go on to the
popos get couples gasps all right
I think this one's gonna be your
favorite oh okay
open oh okay oh my god that's amazing
I love dumplings like I love dumpling
like gyoza
yeah that's your favorite that's my
favorite food thanks peg you like it
and like you go with you yes so you mean
it together
oh yeah that's yeah it's fantastic it's
a good gift we always talk about buying
experiences not like physical things
make a memory not a okay yeah no Kiko's
speaking of making memories another
thing that we're gonna be doing together
and making a memory with okay
[Music]
we literally are buying our tickets
right before we got here we're going to
Tokyo next year that's a good one
because it's something we're doing
something good
I mean buying me a ticket to Tokyo would
be a little better here no I'm thrilled
it's not as good on the it's the thought
that counts
but also the gifts are good too I think
if I would have had the actual artwork
here on time I would say I have an a
minus a minus B plus for execution and
what about you so I would say B plus
overall yeah no I'd say I'd say hey my
buddy give me a yeah what a treat I'm
feeling generous cuz it's the holiday
season
okay we're gonna go use these now let's
do it that's got those lame it's okay
thank you I'm not good at this I gotta
work on this yeah okay just started
putting up my new light
oh babe this is why we should just get
people our wish list so there's no
guessing at what would be useful and for
me an almost 30 old woman it's disco
lights
[Music]
[Music]